j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
comme chaque soir cette semaine vous le
savez il est consacré aux conséquences
de la guerre en Ukraine un an après
l'invasion russe gros plan sur la
situation militaire et l'extraordinaire
résistance
ukrainienne on va d'abord détailler les
territoires gagnés ou perdus depuis 12
mois avec Fabien avec elle
des soldats Ukrainiens défendent leur
position près de barmouth cette localité
de l'est de l'Ukraine devenue
l'épicentre des combats les Russes
poursuivent leur cerclement de la ville
mais les Ukrainiens résistent
ici l'ennemi est très actif mais la
situation est sous contrôle
au bout d'un an de guerre les positions
sont figées par l'hiver quand Vladimir
Poutine attaque le pays sur plusieurs
fronts en février 2022 pourtant on
prédit à l'Ukraine un effondrement
rapide mais la résistance ukrainienne
inflige de lourdes pertes à
l'envahisseur obligé de se retirer du
Nord et de l'Est pour se recentrer sur
le don-basse des offensives russes
mènent à des victoires locales comme
lors du siège de Mario Paul jusqu'à ce
que la fin de l'été sonne la
contre-offensive ukrainienne des
milliers de kilomètres carrés de
territoires sont reconquis la ville de
Kerson dans le sud est libérée nous
arrivons pas à pas dans tous les
territoires temporairement occupés de
notre
mais les Ukrainiens tributaires des
livraisons de matériels européens
doivent cesser leur effort à partir de
mi-novembre l'armée russe reprend alors
l'initiative au prix de très lourdes
pertes une offensive en trompe l'oeil
analyse cette historien militaire pas de
percée à ce jour ce sont des poussées en
grignote le front de quelques centaines
de mètres sachant que ces opérations-là
en réalité non pour objectif principal
que de travailler dans nos esprits de
nous montrer que l'armée russe est
toujours là et qu'il faut cesser de
soutenir l'Ukraine donc il y a une
rationalité cachée dans cette séquence
d'opération là qui est de travailler sur
les perceptions puisque sur le terrain
en tout cas l'armée russe n'a plus la
capacité de renverser la situation reste
à savoir si l'armée ukrainienne aura la
capacité de déclencher une nouvelle
contre-offensive au printemps face à la
menace du nouvel mobilisation de masse
en Russie les Ukrainiens sont engagés
dans une course contre la montre dans
l'attente de nouvelles livraisons
d'armements occidentales
un an de résistance ukrainienne c'est le
thème de notre débat avec Irina
mitrychin bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
maître de conférence à l'INALCO
responsable des études
ukrainiennes Hélène blanc bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
politologues spécialiste de la Russie
autrice de ce livre goodbye Poutine du
KGB au crime de guerre publié aux
éditions
Ginko Julien terrots bienvenue à vous
politique spécialisé en conflits
sécurité international vous êtes
enseignant à Sciences Po Paris et
co-auteur avec Isabelle mandro de ce
livre Poutine la stratégie du désordre
jusqu'à la guerre qui lui publier aux
éditions tallendier Mathilde Sirault
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
éditorialiste pour sens publique avant
de vous entendre sur la situation
aujourd'hui je vous propose de revenir
un an en arrière quand apparaît sur nos
écrans de téléphone portable et de
télévision un homme que peu d'entre nous
connaissent volodièreski
la Russie a mené des frappes sur nos
infrastructures militaires et sur nos
gardes frontières et détachement
frontaliers des explosions ont été
entendues dans de nombreuses villes du
crâne nous imposons la loi martiale dans
toutes les régions de notre état il y a
une minute j'ai eu une conversation
téléphonique avec le président Joe Biden
les États-Unis ont déjà commencé à
préparer le soutien international nous
avons besoin que vous restiez calme
aujourd'hui si possible restez chez vous
encore le costume d'homme politique et
qui depuis ne quitte plus celui de de
chefs d'État en guerre Irina de
mitrychin quel souvenir vous gardez de
ses premiers jours est-ce que vous avez
craint que votre pays cède
oui on l'a on la craint vraiment les
premiers jours était extrêmement
difficile parce qu'on passait notre
temps sur sur à suivre donc les les fils
d'infos on s'endormait dans une espèce
de tension et la première chose qu'on
faisait les quelques heures après c'est
vraiment tremblante prendre son
téléphone et demander si on est toujours
là c'est le pays existe toujours et
je me souviens des premiers postes
Facebook etc et donc vraiment cette nuit
elle restera dans la mémoire
les années il faut se souvenir les
Américains avaient proposé à Zelenski de
l'extré
est-ce que finalement les
Occidentaux nous peut-être aussi de la
liberté ne viendra l'ont sous-est on l'a
sous-estimé mais vous savez je pense
qu'on a sous-estimé en général le peuple
ukrainien que les Français les Européens
connaissent très mal d'où justement
goodbye Poutine parce que c'est juste
pour les gens sachent exactement ce
qu'il faut savoir parce que on nous
raconte tout et n'importe quoi moi je
trouve que les anciens les anciens
ambassadeurs qui viennent sur les
plateaux et qui chacun commettent un
bouquin et qui n'ont pas vu pendant 23
ans l'évolution parce que les
chancellerie occidentales n'ont pas vu
l'évolution de Poutine malheureusement
ils n'ont pas vu comment elle se
radicalisaient et maintenant ils
viennent pérorer sur les plateaux bon je
leur veux pas de mal je trouve quand
même que
mais donc on peut dire est-ce que les
Américains ont sous-estimé aussi la
capacité de résistance du peuple
craignant ou peut-être moins que nous je
pense que tout le monde au départ a
subsisté leur capacité de résistance et
le jour où il a dit bah le premier jour
ou même la première nuit peut-être je ne
veux pas de taxi je veux des armes sa
vie a basculé il était un homme
politique et du coup il a eu un destin
et maintenant il a un destin de chef de
guerre de patrons d'un pays
qu'il souhaite mener à la victoire et
moi j'espère que les Ukrainiens vont
gagner ce n'est pas impossible
contrairement pense que disent beaucoup
de militaires
Julien Theron Vladimir Poutine
connaissait bien volony merzelenski
enfin voilà ça faisait des années qu'il
y avait des négociations enfin est-ce
que pourquoi comment a-t-il pu le
sous-estimer d'après vous je voudrais
quand même préciser une chose dans le
dans la lignée de ce qui vient d'être
dit vous avez pas faite raison il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont sous-estimé à
la fois le peuple crânien le président
ukrainien mais je me permets sans
pérorer justement mais de dire que je je
connais un certain nombre d'analystes
qui ont été extrêmement justes sur cette
question
j'ai vu il y a pas longtemps la
direction d'un institut militaire
expliqué qu'on ne pouvait pas le savoir
à ce moment-là je peux citer des
articles et j'ai moi-même d'ailleurs
écrit sur ce sujet là avant c'était
possible combien de temps avant combien
de temps avant alors les articles dont
je parle je fais une étude justement sur
ce sujet sont les plus récents sont je
crois que c'est début novembre 2022 et
en central le plus nombreux les
débutants
21 et les plus nombreux sont en général
en janvier d'accord mais ça veut dire
qu'il était possible de le voir jeudi
juste ça parce que c'est très important
pour la défense de nos démocratie de
dire qu'il est possible d'analyser
correctement précisément à la fois
l'avenir Poutine les actions militaires
et si je me souviens bien les Américains
ont commencé à alerter là aussi
plusieurs semaines avant le
déclenchement de l'offensif et la grande
tonalité en France notamment donc sur
les plateaux était de dire que c'était
de la larmisme je m'en souviens et
d'ailleurs même le jour d'après j'ai vu
arriver sur les plateaux les mêmes
personnes qui la veillent disaient que
c'était de la larmisme expliqué d'autres
choses voilà bon c'est juste pour dire
que aujourd'hui on est dans un état si
on s'en réfère au discours sur l'état de
l'Union de l'état de l'adresse à la
nation
russe donc de Vladimir Poutine de notre
jour on est dans une situation où il dit
la guerre c'est avec l'Occident elle
dure depuis 2014 c'est comme ça donc il
faut bien comprendre la situation on se
trouve et que cet aspect de
l'information et de l'analyse des choses
et vraiment de extrêmement stratégique
on se demande si les
Ukrainiens n'ont pas été pris au sérieux
au départ mais en réalité ce qui s'est
passé au tout début les heures qui ont
précédé déclenchement de la guerre et
les premiers heures de la guerre on
s'est rendu compte que les alarmes
avaient été en effet faites notamment on
n'a pas des Américains sur la capacité à
Vladimir Poutine d'agir mais que ça n'a
pas vraiment été entendu ou pris au
sérieux c'est ce qui s'est passé
en 2014 que Poutine a commencé à penser
à préparer son opération spéciale et
c'est un peu exercer en Tchétchénie où
il a fait des choses épouvantables enfin
son armée bien sûr mais la Tchétchénie
c'était en Russie vous comprenez il
était chez lui mais quand il a envahi la
Géorgie
très curieusement il a pas eu de
sanction les Européens n'ont pas bougé
n'en n'ont pas tiré la leçon
idem pour la Syrie bon je veux dire mais
là quand même l'Ukraine première partie
c'est à dire la Crimée et le Dombas on
n'a pas beaucoup bougé non plus sauf
qu'on a pas reconnu ces annexions qui
étaient d'ailleurs illégales bon ça
c'est vrai mais après si vous voulez moi
je pense que je me souviens d'un sommet
de la cui la comité le comité des États
indépendants qui a remplacé l'URSS ou la
plupart des anciennes républiques
soviétiques étaient à l'intérieur et il
avait dit en 2006 à sa cache Willy qui
était alors le président de la Géorgie
il avait dit tu sais je vais envahir la
Géorgie et bien ça cacheuli ne l'a pas
cru et en 2008 il l'a fait parce que si
vous voulez il faut écouter ce qu'il dit
le problème c'est qu'il fait toujours ce
qu'il dit seulement ça apparaît dans un
espèce de salmigondit une espèce de si
j'ose dire où il y a des tas de choses
il y a de la religion il y a de
l'histoire d'ailleurs mal enfin
révisionniste disons en tout cas mal cru
mal expliqué l'histoire il fait des des
raccourcis extraordinaires mais enfin
quand on connaît un peu les choses on
remet les choses dans le contexte mais
sinon
vraiment il faut écouter ce qu'il dit et
là aussi les Européens n'ont pas encore
compris je crois même aujourd'hui à quel
point moi si vous les j'écoute beaucoup
les gens je vais dans des salons du
livre je fais des conférences je vais
sur les plateaux et j'écoute ce qu'on
dit est-ce qu'on me dit c'est oh bah tu
sais Poutine il est pas si mal
finalement bon chacun à l'opinion qui le
qu'il veut avoir c'est pas le problème
enfin les gens n'ont pas encore compris
que cette guerre à travers l'Ukraine
c'est à nous qu'il l'a fait et à l'OTAN
qu'il ne supporte pas je voudrais qu'on
fasse un point sur la situation actuelle
je vous propose une carte du du front
ukrainien et et selon le président
d'ailleurs Zelenski c'est au tour des de
la ville de backhout essentiellement
également la ville de bougulédard que la
situation est la plus difficile ou la
plus critique pour les troupes
ukrainiennes on parle Irina de mitrychin
d'une situation figée depuis quelques
jours ou quelques semaines mais les
combats ils continuent ils sont
extrêmement violents est-ce qu'on sait
combien de soldats sont morts des deux
côtés ou est-ce que c'est un presque un
tabou ou une donnée qu'on ne veut qui
est volontairement tenue secrète ça
alors côté ukrainien les données sont
tenues secrètes et je dirais que ça fait
partie d'une source de consensus dans la
société on cherche non pas non plus à
percer ce secret peut-être parce qu'on a
peur de retrouver aussi les chiffres
épouvantables ou parce que on estime que
le sacrifice est nécessaire aujourd'hui
et donc tout le monde prend sa part donc
en tout cas il n'y a pas de critique de
de du fait que les demandes de
transparence là-dessus parce que ça
pourrait s'appeler le moral de la
population des troupes oui si les
chiffres sont extrêmement importants et
puis en revanche l'Ukraine prépare sa
son offensive donc il y a par exemple
une nouvelle nouveau recrutement sur
base de volontariat qui avait été
proposé et il y a eu des dizaines de
milliers de de monde donc ce qui veut
dire que la société ukrainienne est
prête à générer de de combattants et des
gens qui sont prêtes à s'engager dans la
situation présente même en sachant qu'il
y a déjà un an de guerre ça veut dire
donc le la mobilisation elle se fait
aussi sur la base du volontariat c'est
ce que vous êtes en train de nous
expliquer c'est comme ça que fonctionne
l'armée ukrainienne aujourd'hui Julien
Terron
la situation militaire aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elle est figée j'employé ce
terme là tout à l'heure ou pas juste
pour répondre à votre question on a une
évaluation du côté russe c'est une
évaluation les renseignement britannique
estime à 60 000 morts de soldats dont
russe tués sur le front
et en général on pour ceux qui sont en
incapacité de combattre donc ceux qui
ont déserté ceux qui sont fait
prisonniers et ceux qui sont blessés
donc on a aussi une évaluation à peu
près à 200 000 qui sont hors combats en
un an ce qui est absolument considérable
je veux dire par rapport à ce qui était
la capacité de de mobilisation de
l'armée russe des gens ils avaient moins
de 200000 hommes au départ et puis même
si on compare à des guerres bon des sers
des guerriers régulières mais tout de
même très violente comme en Afghanistan
ou enfin sur un miracle on est on est
dans la démultiplication complète de ce
qui s'est passé sur 20 ans donc on
comprend qu'on est vraiment dans un dans
une logique extrême et pardon votre
question donc alors ma question c'était
c'était de savoir si la situation était
effectivement figée sur le front là on a
vu une carte depuis plusieurs semaines
ou est-ce qu'il y a une offensive ou une
avancée russe comme certains le disent
il y a une offensive mais il y a pas
d'avancée il y a une offensive mais pas
d'avance en fait l'avancée minime de
temps en temps elle existe il faut
reconnaître mais on a calculé même le
nombre de morts russes qu'il fallait
pour avancer de 100 mètres et c'est
absolument considérable c'est à dire que
ils envoient des vagues d'assaut
complètes qui se font tuer par les
Ukrainiens qui eux-mêmes sont
extrêmement surpris de voir tout ces
russes safalaient sur eux et c'est un
mode de guerre qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui en fait c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment très surprenant
j'entendais encore aujourd'hui un
commentaire expliquant que les temps
crush utilisent très rarement les
fumigènes qui visent à camoufler en fait
l'action du temps qui est en fait à
éviter les tirs tout en se demandant
c'est si c'est parce qu'ils sont mal
formés ou que ils n'ont pas spécialement
l'intention de se cacher pourtant une en
russe on avait sa masquerov car ça vient
de l'empire tsariste déjà et c'était un
des fleurons de l'armée russe qui
faisait ça c'est à dire qui était très
doué justement pour ce camoufler dans
l'action et aujourd'hui ils ne le font
plus donc c'est à dire que vous
l'expliquer ça parce que ça dans les
premières semaines ou premier mois de
guerre bon et éventuellement mais le
temps passant on rédite pas les mêmes
erreurs je pense qu'il y a tout un tas
de
d'hypothèses dans ces hypothèses il y a
un rapport à la violence probablement
beaucoup de ces vagues d'assaut viennent
de la compagnie Wagner et les 4/5
sortent des prisons donc c'est déjà des
gens qui ont été jugés en général des
criminaires qui ont été exposés à une
violence extrême aussi dans les prisons
russes toujours les Russes le savent
parfaitement il y a eu des études qui
ont été faites sur le sujet et qui sont
prises par donc un groupe qui n'a aucune
forme de légalité pour être envoyé sur
un front dans une guerre d'agression où
on leur dit allez-y allez combattre en
leur donnant à ce peu de matériel enfin
je veux dire tout est hyper violent
jusqu'à ce moment là donc il y a cette
question là il y a aussi le la question
peut-être du rapport à la guerre comme
vous le disiez à très juste titre il y a
une montée en puissance au moins depuis
2007 pour pas dire depuis 1999 c'est à
dire depuis le début en réalité chez
Vladimir Poutine sur le rapport à la
violence au sein de la société russe et
au sein de la société internationale
qui est déployé dans les discours auprès
des Russes par exemple yunarmia qui est
l'association des jeunes qui est monté
par la ministre par le ministère de la
Défense donc déjà si vous voulez c'est
une forme de scoutisme militaire et le
ministre schoigoul lui-même a dit vous
pourrez tirer avec tout sauf avec les
missiles balistiques et les il y a des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes dans
cette organisation et maintenant on est
en train de recréer des programmes
scolaires abandonnés je crois que c'est
en 1993 après l'union soviétique pour
donner un entraînement militaire à la
population aux enfants
vous imaginez qu'on n'a pas du tout le
même rapport à la violence dans nos
sociétés on est quasiment dans les
tendances strictement inverse où on est
en train de débattre dans nos structures
éducatives du fait que le contrôle ou la
dictée c'est quand même un peu oppressif
pour les enfants enfin je vous rendez
compte de du faux ça me rappelle la
scène d'ouverture du film à l'ouest rien
de nouveau où on voit la mobilisation
des des jeunes lycéens Allemands ils ont
à peine 17 ou 18 ans on leur dit vous
avez marché vers Paris ils sont
galvanisés par ça et puis évidemment ils
découvrent les tranchées et ce qui est
la guerre de de 14-18 en quelques heures
je voudrais parce que vous venez de nous
dire nous décrire une armée russe quand
même qui qui fait la guerre à l'ancienne
ou à l'envers je sais pas quel terme
employé écoutez ce qu'on dit le
président russe c'est dans une vidéo qui
a été publiée aujourd'hui par le Kremlin
à l'occasion de la Fête militaire
nationale du défenseur de la patrie
Vladimir Poutine
nous continuerons à saturer les troupes
avec des équipements de pointe il s'agit
de nouveaux systèmes de frappe
d'équipement de reconnaissance et de
communication de drones et de systèmes
d'artillerie aujourd'hui notre industrie
augmentera rapidement la production de
toute la gamme d'armes conventionnelle
mettent au point la production en série
des modèles les plus récents pour
l'armée la flotte et les forces
aérospatiales
évidemment on est dans de la propagande
Hélène blanc mais est-ce qu'il y a une
part de vérité dans la capacité quand
même russe à produire des armes et des
armes de qualité de qualité je ne sais
pas parce que un des grands problèmes de
cette armée qui date de l'air soviétique
c'est la corruption au plus haut niveau
rappelez-vous enfin 91 quand au moment
où l'URSS implosé
les soldats qui n'étaient plus payés
depuis un bon moment on commençait à
vendre des armes les soldats de base des
révoltes de RD kalashnikov etc et les
hauts gradés eux vendaient des atomique
des chats rouillés enfin tout ce qui
pouvait trouver parce que sous eltine
malheureusement la les salaires
n'étaient plus payés les bourses
n'étaient plus payées les retraites non
plus et donc l'armée elle a eu vraiment
un gros problème de corruption et je
pense que ça continue aujourd'hui
malheureusement ce qui explique
peut-être que justement l'armement qui
coûte très cher l'armement moderne fait
que qui est absent plus ou moins qu'il
était en tout cas c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont ressortis les vieux chats enfin ils
font une guerre à l'ancienne ils font
une guerre même pas du XXème siècle mais
du 19e à mon avis il y avait pas de char
à l'époque c'est vrai mais le dire c'est
une guerre soviétique ce n'est pas une
guerre russe c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre mais vous savez qu'en Poutine
est arrivé en 2000 au pouvoir il a
immédiatement remilitariser la société
il a pris une il a adopté une nouvelle
charte de guerre enfin il a pris tout un
tas de lois qui permettait d'aller à
l'étranger défendre des populations
francophones russophone pardon
maltraitée voyez enfin je veux dire il
avait déjà mon avis alors au début il a
un tout petit peu fait attention à
l'opinion occidentale un tout petit peu
c'est-à-dire qui s'est pas précipité le
1er jour pour réhabiliter Staline il a
attendu un tout petit peu de 3 ans à
peine ou quatre ans peut-être c'est tout
mais sinon après il s'est dit il s'est
fâché avec l'OTAN parce qu'au départ les
relations autant Russie étaient bonnes
ils ont ils ont même proposé d'entrer
dans l'OTAN ce qui était assez drôle
parce que quand on se rappelle pourquoi
l'OTAN a été créé mais enfin bon et puis
finalement un moment il a complètement
laissé tomber tout ça il a tourné le dos
à l'OTAN enfin je veux dire c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai compris que il y
avait un souci et qu'il allait nous
réserver de m'avait surprise je voudrais
qu'on parle de de la flamme de la
résistance ukrainienne c'est aussi le
thème un peu central de ce de ce débat
et je vais malheureusement commencer par
des des des trucs qui sont donnés par le
Haut Commissariat des Nations Unies aux
Droits de l'Homme sur les victimes
civils 7199 civils Ukrainiens tués dont
461 enfants
11.756 blessés dont 926 enfants les
morts les blessés c'est ce dont nous
parlent ces Ukrainiens qui reviennent
sur l'année de guerre on en écoutant
comment peux-tu te sentir bien quand
quelqu'un meurt tous les jours quand mes
amis dans d'autres villes écrivent
qu'ici une bombe est tombée que là-bas
quelqu'un est mort que là-bas un
camarade de classe a été tué comment
peux-tu te sentir bien bien sûr ça n'est
pas agréable mais la vie continue et il
faut continuer à vivre
ce fut l'année la plus difficile de ma
vie et de celle de tous les Ukrainiens
[Musique]
je suis sûr que la victoire est devant
nous mais nous ne savons pas combien de
temps nous devons encore attendre ni
combien de victimes il y aura avant
cette victoire c'est la seule chose
maintenant qui préoccupe tous les
Ukrainiens
je suis où il est temps sont très dur on
ne peut pas les comparer à la vie
d'avant
mais il y a la vie tout comme le
printemps qui arrive
la victoire viendra parce que le bien
gagne toujours
qui arrive la victoire viendra parce que
le bien gagne toujours
dans cette flamme ukrainienne dans cette
capacité de résistance on parlait des
armes il y a aussi une capacité à
produire des armes il n'y a pas parce
qu'on dit toujours
la parole réclame réclame des armes et
on peut le comprendre mais vous en
produisez aussi
Ukraine en produit aussi le crâne un
produit aussi d'ailleurs qui qui font
leur preuve je crois que le croiseur
mosquois a été abattu avec une arme
ukrainienne donc il y a quand même aussi
l'Ukraine aussi avait avant cette guerre
pourtant a été prévenu n'a pas vraiment
cru et qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure de
déclaration occidentale mais les
Ukrainiens aussi étaient dans cette
optique en disant que tout cela va faire
du mal non
etc il y avait pas une surproduction
d'armes de la part de l'Ukraine dans les
mois qui ont précédé par exemple
est venu avec la présidence Zelinski a
été élu contrairement à Porto qui
parlait que Poutine allait aller à
réattaquer qu'il fallait préparer
l'armée s'organiser etc est venu sur le
discours de paix sur le fait qu'elle
allait s'entendre que il faut construire
les routes il faut développer l'économie
etc etc et donc c'est la guerre qui a
fait de Zelinski en fait lui affaire
reprendre les tests de porschenko et de
tout ce que tout ce que a été fait
pendant cette présidence mais est-ce que
c'est c'est ces infrastructures
industrielles militaires sont toujours
debout parce que on voit que les les
frappes russes elles visent les
infrastructures depuis plusieurs mois
alors l'usine la plus enfin il y a
beaucoup de villes de l'est qui ont été
des grandes centres de production tels
que de ni pro etc n'oublions pas que le
fleuron de l'industrie soviétique dans
l'armement dans l'aéron était anukraine
les l'usine de zapporis donc de
motorcitch qui qui produisait les
moteurs pour l'ensemble pratiquement de
l'aviation militaire et civile
soviétique était asapolisa le bureau en
tenant était à cueillir donc il y a à la
fois à la base technique si vous voulez
les cerveaux et la production militaire
Julien parle maintenant des armes
occidentales on a beaucoup parlé des
armes lourdes et des chars des chats
américains britanniques des chars on va
dire d'originalement est-ce qu'ils sont
est-ce que ils commencent à être livré
ou est-ce qu'on est encore dans la phase
intermédiaire entre la promesse et la
livraison les deux il y en a qui sont
arrivés c'est le début ça arrive
lentement il y en a
un certain nombre mais c'est pas énorme
et si vous voulez vous savez pourquoi
vous la diverses qui réclament des armes
parce que cette guerre consomme des
arbres des arbres c'est à dire que c'est
pas on livre des armes et puis une fois
et puis c'est bon ces armes
disparaissent sont détruites et donc il
en faut tout le temps en fait sans
parler des munitions d'ailleurs et
encore les Ukrainiens
tirent bien moins d'obus que les Russes
parfois il s'étonne aussi autre surprise
que les Russes tirent de manière
complètement aléatoire par exemple s'il
y a des positions dans la forêt ils
essaient même pas de savoir où sont les
positions ukrainiennes ils tirent dans
toute la forêt ils arrosent la forêt
complètement d'obus et les Ukrainiens
tiens en réalité beaucoup moins de
munitions les Ukrainiens sont ont besoin
de munitions tous les jours et ils n'en
n'ont pas assez pour faire l'équivalent
des Russes juste peut-être juste un
point sur ce qu'on disait sur les armes
russes du point de vue russe il y a un
peu des deux c'est à dire qu'ils
arrivent quand même à faire un peu de
high-tech mais qui donne en général au
VDV au spinner toutes les unités d'élite
et en réalité il y a quand même beaucoup
de
le président russe quand même en rajoute
quand même beaucoup sur la capacité
fantasmagorique des armes russes au sens
strict du terme parce que parce que
quand on voit sur le terrain les
performances par exemple de leur temps
que 90 aiment le plus récent
il se fait aussi détruire par les
missiles en Titan que comme les temps
que précédents et là il en a même parlé
un petit peu dans son discours du
dernier T14 qu'on a vu juste pendant le
défilé du 9 mai alors tous les ans on se
demande si on va en voir plus on en voit
jamais plus et en fait si vous voyez
c'est des prototypes ils ont des
prototypes et c'est pareil pour les
missiles
donc ils essayent de produire ça mais il
y a quand même un point qui est très
important c'est qu'il a expliqué dans
son discours aussi que il allait faire
une loi spéciale pour payer le loyer des
ouvriers qui travailleraient dans les
usines d'armement et ça ça augure d'un
empirement d'ailleurs qu'il annonce
aussi très clairement en disant ça va
être pire en pire donc ça oui il
anticipe le fait tu vas demander aux
ouvriers de ces villes la trappe de
travailler encore plus il dit ce qui est
vrai qu'ils sont déjà en 3 à 8 et en
gros il prend des mesures pour augmenter
la force de production en capacité sur
la livraison des armes
occidentales et particulièrement
européennes qu'est-ce que vous dites du
voilà des délais
que l'on assiste aujourd'hui et que
c'est que vous êtes assez critique donc
voilà que ce soit clair mais je trouve
quand même que par rapport à ce que
demande il est en général il demande
exactement ce dont les Ukrainiens ont
besoin à un instant T il y a toujours un
temps de retard pour les livraisons
d'armes je trouve s'ils avaient le
fonctionnement à 25 ans je sais que
c'est compliqué que mais je veux dire il
faut anticiper et j'ai pas l'impression
que ça soit le cas vous voyez ce que je
veux dire parce que si j'avais eu les
temps enfin tout ce qu'il demande
maintenant depuis un moment déjà s'ils
avaient eu tout ça en décembre ou en
janvier ils auraient pu lancer une
contre-offensive et c'est le moment
maintenant parce que les Russes sont en
train de patiner un petit peu alors ils
veulent en fait lancer une grande
offensive mais elle n'est pas prête
semble-t-il et donc c'était le moment de
les prendre par surprise mais là ils
peuvent pas puisqu'ils n'ont pas ce
qu'ils ont demandé
donc ça vous êtes pessimiste sur le pape
pessimiste parce que je sais que les
Ukrainiens vont compenser ce qui leur
manque mais quand même je trouve qu'on
pourrait accélérer un petit peu le
mouvement et nous ne sommes pas encore
nous contrairement à la Russie en
économie de guerre et on devrait l'être
mais qu'est-ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui du rapport de force
concernant les les armées on a
évidemment quand le conflit s'est
déclenché on a beaucoup souligné le fait
que la Russie était davantage voilà doté
en armée etc en homme aussi évidemment
pour mener à bien ce conflit aujourd'hui
on en est où notamment depuis que
l'Union européenne envoie des armes et
des munitions ça c'est rééquilibré de
quelle façon Hélène blanc là-dessus et
ensuite Julien
dans l'imaginaire collectif l'armée
russe c'était la seconde armée du monde
après l'américaine il semblerait que
elle est perdue quelques places quelques
rangs dans ce classement parce que quand
on voit la stratégie russe comparée à la
stratégie ukrainienne il y a quand même
il me semble des petits problèmes dans
le commandement de l'armée russe votre
avis là-dessus sur le rapport de force
en fait
on donne si on compte l'intégralité des
temps qu'on les Russes on pense qu'il y
en a 17000 mais on sait pas du tout dans
quel état il y a ce journaliste
ukrainien qui expliquait que
probablement les Russes eux-mêmes ne le
savent pas et je suis assez convaincu de
ça c'est à dire que on ne sait pas
exactement le parc de char d'assaut et
on part de temps qui sont très anciens
de la part des T55 pour les intégrer
dans dans le florilage donc en réalité
on ne le sait pas on ne le sait pas le
nombre de temps que qu'ils ont mais il
est une chose certaine c'est qu'ils en
ont plus que les Ukrainiens ça c'est sûr
en tout cas on regarde des temps que
occidentaux on parle de 200 qui leur
seraient livrés vous imaginez que c'est
quand même on parle pas du tout des
mêmes chiffres aujourd'hui et alors on
pourrait dire puisque c'était l'idée en
termes de stratégie de développement
d'une production d'armement en Occident
c'est-à-dire on va avoir moins de
matériel mais qui sont beaucoup plus
efficaces alors c'est plus efficace mais
c'est pas forcément beaucoup plus
efficace
c'était un août tout autre ton mardi
dans un enregistrement sur télégram où
il déclarait que les dirigeants de
l'armée régulière russes avaient je le
cite trahi les mercenaires de Wagner en
refusant de leur livrer du matériel dans
l'est de l'Ukraine il avait même demandé
au peuple russe de faire pression sur
les dirigeants pour qu'on lui livre ses
munitions et ce n'est ni la première ni
sans doute la dernière fois qu'il
critiquent l'armée russe regardez par
exemple ce qu'il déclarait il y a
quelques jours
les progrès ne vont pas aussi vite que
nous le souhaiterions je pense qu'avant
le Nouvel An nous aurions pu prendre
backmout si nous n'avions pas cette
monstrueuse bureaucratie militaire qui
nous met des bâtons dans les roues
chaque jour
voilà c'est propos montrent bien le
niveau de tension qu'il existe
aujourd'hui entre le ministère de la
Défense russe et les ministres de Wagner
pris d'origine qui parle d'opposition
frontale qui se dispute avec les
généraux russes la paternité de victoire
de terrain qui avait déjà signalé une
pénurie totale d'obus vous avez émis une
critique très remarquée en octobre 2022
à propos du retrait russe de la ville de
Limane dans la province de Donetsk il
avait alors pensé les généraux avec ses
mots qu'on envoie tous ces [__] au
front avec des mitrailleuses et pieds
nus des propos qui venaient en plus
contredire le récit de Moscou qui
tentait de minimiser le coup de cette
défaite pris d'origine que l'on a
longtemps présenté comme l'homme de base
d'oeuvre de Poutine semble donc
aujourd'hui s'émanciper même s'il n'a
jamais jusqu'ici franchi la ligne qui
consisterait à critiquer directement le
chef du Kremlin alors on surnomme le
cuisinier de Poutine quel est son
parcours c'est un gangster il a passé 10
ans en prison dans les années 80 avant
de devenir un homme d'affaires qui a la
chute de l'URSS en 1996 remporte des
contrats juteux pour fournir les
cantines scolaires et la restauration de
l'armée d'où le cuisinier de Poutine
c'est alors qu'il se lit aussi avec les
plus hautes sphères du pouvoir et puis
sa mutation commence au tournant des
années 2010 lorsqu'il se spécialise dans
le musulman de la liberté de
d'expression et de l'opposition sur le
web et ça va devenir l'une de ces
marques de fabrique le contrôle de
l'information l'une des spécialités de
Wagner aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec les
vidéos de propagande en Afrique on en a
parlé sur ce plateau Wagner dont il a
confirmé être les créateur seulement en
septembre 2022 à cette occasion il a
fait remonter la date de formation du
groupe à 2014 c'était alors dit-il des
volontaires russes qui intervenaient
dans le don-basse évidemment la dernière
question qui est importante on lui prête
des ambitions politiques et oui les
observateurs aujourd'hui s'interrogent
sur ses ambitions personnelles on l'a vu
devenir une personnalité publique de
premier point à mesure aussi qu'il
arpentait les prisons pour recruter de
nouveau un musicien pour remplacer les
hommes perdus sur le front
ukrainien et certains sites russes
expliquent déjà qu'il est en train de
préparer le lancement d'un mouvement
politique
ultra conservateur et ultra nationaliste
ce qu'il a nié au mois d'octobre et à
Saint-Pétersbourg il a aussi tenté de
faire élire des proches au législatives
sous du parti nationaliste Rodina alors
prépare-t-il déjà l'après Poutine telle
est la question merci tempo pour ces
explications Irina mitrychin avant de
parler de peut-être du pouvoir de
Vladimir Poutine et de ce que représente
trilogie dans ce contexte le ces
paramilitaire Wagner que sait-on de des
exactions qu'il commettent sur le
terrain en Ukraine
c'est qu'ils sont utilisés dans les
points les plus chauds justement
aujourd'hui et qu'ils sont envoyés donc
les personnes à 80% c'est à dire qu'ils
sont utilisés vraiment pour saturer le
front ukrainien pour les exactions il y
a eu d'autres troupes quand même dont
les troupes régulières russes qui ont
commis notamment ce n'est pas seulement
ce ne sont pas seulement les les
musiciens Wagner qui sont illustrés par
anukraine en tout cas avec cela
Prigogine a promis de prendre le
territoire ou les villes que l'armée
régulière n'a pas réussi à apprendre lui
non plus n'a pas n'a pas tellement
avancé et
pour l'instant on a davantage le fait
d'annonce et de cette présence
médiatique de de
des Wagner qui continuent quand même à
être sur le sur le terrain en
remplacement ou en avant poste de
l'armée Hélène blanc on voit bien on l'a
entendu que une priorigine ose
s'attaquer frontalement à l'armée russe
à la bureaucratie militaire on va dire
ça comme ça et est-ce qu'il est pour
autant en train de s'émanciper d'une
forme de tutelle de Vladimir Poutine ou
alors est-ce que c'est plus compliqué
que ça non je pense qu'il peut pas
s'émanciper en fait Poutine joue les uns
contre les autres pour lui tous ces gens
qui l'entourent sont des pions alors il
y en a qui disparaissent de temps en
temps et puis qui réapparaissent ou pas
vous voyez et il joue avec avec ses gens
selon les besoins qu'il a selon
l'opinion qui l'a sur eux je pense que
polygo a beaucoup exagéré à une époque
en se mettant en scène en étant hablar
en disant tu sais l'armée russe elle est
pas formidable mais moi je vais te
prendre par route etc puis rien du tout
donc je vais dire c'est un peu décevant
pour Poutine il sait que par causer
beaucoup prégo jeune qui a fait des
choses quand même ne peut pas suppléer
l'armée russe c'est pas possible et puis
en plus il y a une chose que vous avez
remarqué il y a quelques temps que vous
avez dû voir aussi vous savez cette
petite scène ou deux soldats sont en
train d'accrocher le drapeau de Wagner
sur une fenêtre
ce jour là je me suis dit mais pour qui
ce bâtit le prix gauche il se bat pas
pour la Russie devrait mettre le drapeau
russe non ils ont mis le drapeau de
Wagner donc ça c'est quand même assez
intéressant vous voyez et c'est un
personnage ambigu cet homme c'est un
voyou et encore je suis gentille mais en
même temps il peut avoir des ambitions
politiques en même temps il a une énorme
un énorme ego enfin bon et donc quand il
s'est mis en scène qu'il était là à
jouer les hâbleurs je pense que ça a
énervé Poutine parce qu'il ne veut pas
que quelqu'un lui fasse de l'ombre c'est
lui le patron et c'est tout tous les
autres sont en dessous vous voyez je
viens il faut vous l'avez fait écouter
en détail les discours de l'Union
Poutine notamment le discours de la
nation qui était mardi sur l'armée ce
qu'il ce qu'il salue les forces armées
mais il y a ce qu'il dit ce qui ne dit
pas expliquez-nous en fait à un moment
il commence à saluer les forces
terrestres naval et il s'arrête il dit
bon je ne peux pas vraiment tous les
citer alors il s'excuse même alors déjà
le discours était assez
substantiellement long donc bon il a
pris le temps qu'il voulait et
deuxièmement c'est assez surprenant il
s'arrête Il casse son discours et il dit
en fait en préparant ce discours ce qui
est vraiment se mettre en scène en train
de préparer le discours c'est pas du
tout habituel chez lui j'ai voulu faire
la liste de toutes les unités qui sont
battues pour nous mais il y en avait
beaucoup trop ils sont très très
courageux tout ça et en fait c'est une
manière rhétorique de d'oublier Wagner
c'est à dire que de ne pas citer Wagner
et hop on ne cite pas Wagner qui est au
regard de de de du positionnement
tactique de Wagner extrêmement important
dans les combats mais de ne pas le citer
donc il se maintient je vous parlais de
fantasmagori tout à l'heure il se
maintient dans cette idée qu'en fait
c'est que l'armée alors qu'à ce groupe
qui a des pouvoirs extraordinaires qui
fait sortir des gens de prison sans
l'intermédiation d'un juge qui les
envoie combattre donc on se demande pour
qui se battent mais ils ont quand même
un appui feu des munitions de l'armée et
il faut bien voir que le remplacement du
chef d'état-major des opérations en
Ukraine par Valérie guérinov qui a le
chef d'état-major de l'armée russe des
forces armées russes et très politiques
c'est une manière de dire on va
reprendre les choses en main et pardon
c'est un feuilleton mais justement on
est dans un feuilleton politique au sein
du régime puisque il y a deux trois
jours donc prigogène explique que en
fait il y a des traîtres qui ne lui
livrent pas les munitions dont il a
besoin qui ne mettent pas à son service
les avions pour faire venir les hommes
sur le front et hier il a dit
aujourd'hui ce matin j'ai reçu des
munitions et pourquoi il dit j'ai reçu
des munitions ces politiques aussi il
explique que il dit vous voyez
si je farcis la voix ah oui l'état
m'obéit c'est une façon de montrer son
pouvoir c'est parce que j'ai crié que
j'ai c'est aussi politique
puisque Wagner n'existe pas vous savez
bien qu'officiellement c'est de
mercenaire est interdit en Russie donc
je veux dire c'est un peu compliqué tout
ça bien sûr est-ce qu'on sait juste quel
est le l'état de l'opinion russe
vis-à-vis de Wagner et de et de
Prigogine justement c'est très difficile
à savoir alors il y a des sondages
d'opinion qui sont faits par l'Institut
levada notamment qui est un institut
extrêmement sérieux qu'on peut pas
mettre en cause mais je pense que
lorsqu'on ils font des micro-trottoirs
je pense que les gens ne répondent pas
ce qu'ils pensent vraiment parce que ils
savent très bien ce qui risque donc il
voulait y répondre oui que bon la guerre
enfin d'ailleurs c'est pas une guerre en
espace c'est toujours pas une guerre
alors que j'ai quelqu'un qui m'a dit
d'ailleurs je comprends pas c'est pas du
tout une guerre j'ai dit ah bon les gens
sont extraordinaires mais bon il y a des
morts il y a des décombres il y a des
bombardements il y a des des enlèvements
d'enfants enfin je veux dire il y a tout
ce qui tous les appareils tous les
toutes les apparences d'une guerre enfin
bon bref passons si vous voulez je pense
que oui on ne sait pas exactement or là
où je suis inquiète pour la Russie la
Russie éternelle je veux dire pas celle
de Poutine que ce soit clair il ne pense
pas à l'avenir de son pays il est en
train de l'emmener dans le mur et il y a
des générations de jeunes qui vont
continuer à s'en aller or leur
démographie est en chute libre donc il
va arriver à un moment où la population
va diminuer
et on se dit que vraiment il n'en a rien
à faire ni de la nature humaine ni de la
vie de quelqu'un puisque les on voit
bien comment la chair à canon est
envoyée au combat il n'en a rien à faire
même de son peuple ni de son pays
c'était extraordinaire et il veut
simplement laisser son nom dans
l'histoire comme celui qui a repris la
Crimée et le don-basse notamment aux
Ukrainiens je veux dire c'est un peu
petit d'abord mais en même temps je
pense qu'il voudrait profiter de la vie
parce que c'est l'homme le plus riche du
monde à l'heure actuelle il faut savoir
ça c'est il a accumulé une fortune il a
commencé à trafiquer quand il était
encore en Allemagne et il a annoncé des
fortunes mais dont on a même perdu le
compte parce que chaque contrat qui est
signé un contrat commercial il touche un
pourcentage chaque litre de de pétrole
ou de chaque petit machin de gaz je sais
pas comment on appelle ça des
hectolitres il touche vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est le parrain de la
Russie tout dernier mot Irina mitrychin
malheureusement on est arrivé à une
année de guerre
une année d'invasion parce que la guerre
dure depuis 2014 et vous avez raison
30000 victimes avant vous avez raison
non mais vous avez raison une année
d'invasion
le peuple ukrainien se prépare à
ce que ça dure beaucoup plus longtemps
dans quel état d'esprit vous
compatriotes sont par rapport à ça
la jeune fille a parlé de après la
victoire donc les Ukrainiens ne doute
absolument pas les sondages frôle 95% de
pignon sur le fait que la victoire sera
ukrainienne et les Ukrainiens pensent
déjà à cette victoire à ce prix qui est
terrible qui sert à payer mais surtout à
la reconstruction du pays après et on
sera là pour en parler évidemment merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat j'ai rappelé rapidement le
titre de vos livres laine blanc goodbye
Poutine aux éditions gynco et Julien
Theron Poutine la stratégie jusqu'à la
guerre c'est aux éditions Talandier on
est un peu en retard merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité demain matin 8h
oralement signé aura face à elle
l'ancien Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
Raffin bonne soirée
[Musique]